DEBORA ELKIN: Hello, and
welcome to this session.
My name is Debora Elkin, and
I'm a technical solutions
consultant with Google Cloud.
I'll be presenting this
session with Warren Vella.
He's an enterprise
integration architect
with the Australian
Energy Market Operator.
In this session, we
will see how APIs
can help you unlock the
power of your existing data
and how the Australian
Energy Market Operator is
leveraging Apache to do so.
We will also see
AEMO's APIs in action.
We all know that this is the
age of connective experiences.
Your customers, or your
customers' customers,
want to interact with
applications and data
in different ways, in
different channels,
on different platforms.
These interactions are
constantly changing,
and everything's connected
with everything else.
APIs are key enablers
of digital experiences.
Think how pervasive Google
Maps or how booking systems
have made our lives easier.
Of course, this data involved
in all digital experiences,
whether it be available flights
on a travel booking system
or your bank account
details in online banking
or just about anything
you can think of, really.
However, the data you need to
build these digital experiences
is often buried deep within a
company's systems of record.
It could be in data
warehouse, data lakes, files
that could be scattered
everywhere, disparate systems,
legacy systems
have to connect to.
This data is most likely
locked away, hard to get at,
and it takes a lot of
time to surface it.
So somewhere, there is a system
of record, holding data that
is hard to get at.
It can take months or years
to make the changes required
to make that data available.
But customer or consumer's
expectations are high.
They want the digital
experience that
is underpinned by that data,
and they want it quick.
This is where API
management fits in.
It fills the gap between
the systems of record
and the requirements of
new digital experiences.
It helps organizations build a
bridge between legacy systems
and mother applications.
And it can build that bridge
in a secure, reliable,
and scalable way.
So let's talk about Apigee.
Apigee is Google Cloud's API
management platform, not just
an API gateway, and
gives you all the tools
you need for unlocking
your data via APIs.
Apigee enables digital
business acceleration
with a unified and complete
platform, purpose-built
for the digital economy.
Apigee makes it easier to
manage the entire digital volume
chain with API services,
developer services,
and analytic services.
Let's start at the
bottom with API services.
This is the API runtime
and mediation engine.
API services lets you manage
the connection between the API
consumers and the
back-end service.
You have complete control
over the request and response.
You can add security, transform
requests and responses,
orchestrate calls
across multiple systems
impose rate limits and
quotas and prevent people
from using your services.
API analytics helps you
measure, tune, and monitor
your API program.
It enables end-to-end visibility
across the digital value chain
with developer analytics,
operational and business
metrics, reports
about app performance,
and custom reports
that you may need.
All are necessary to
monitor, measure, and manage
success of your API program.
Developer services enable a
great developer and community
experience that accelerates API
adoption, simplifies learning,
and increases the
business value of APIs.
It provides a developer
portal for your API consumers,
along with features for
packaging, monetizing
your services and data.
When you're sharing
your data, you
want to make sure you
do this in a secure way.
When we talk about
security, there
are many different aspects.
For instance, data should
only reach the right audience.
This is where authentication
and authorization come in.
In that respect, Apigee
supports widely used standards,
such as OAuth and
OpenID Connect.
You also don't want
anyone snooping
around when the
data is in transit.
This is where encryption
plays a key role.
Apigee supports TLS,
mutual TLS, and can
support different configuration
of these protocols
when communicating with API
clients and back-end services
that hold it back.
For example, you may configure
one-way TLS on the client side,
but mutual TLS list for
one of your back-ends
and one-way TLS for another.
Auditing is also very important.
You need to know who has
access to what data, who
has made a change to the
API that exposes that data.
Apigee auditing and logging
capabilities have you covered.
Also, is this sensitive data?
No problem.
Use an Apigee extension
to quickly redact data
with GCP data loss
prevention services.
You could potentially think of
making money out of your data
as well--
that is, if you wish to.
Of course, not all APIs should
necessarily be monetized.
There are APIs that
built consumer experience
or drive indirect value.
They should be
free-- for instance,
think about API
for ticket booking,
finding store locations,
product availability, et cetera.
On the other hand, if
your APIs help developers
build apps that
generate revenue,
you may consider
charging for those APIs--
for example, APIs
that provide weather
data or messaging services.
Apigee API monetization
offers multiple options
to set up charge plans.
You can configure fee-based
plans, volume-based plans.
You can set up revenue
sharing with developers,
freemium models, et cetera.
It also allows you to check
monetization plan limits
during API execution.
In short, whether you want to
build new digital experiences,
create a partner ecosystem, or
apply artificial intelligence
or machine learning to your
data, unlocking your data
is the key.
And APIs are the
way to achieve this.
We will now see how the
Australian Energy Market
Operator is unlocking
its data and putting it
to effective work
in an ecosystem.
I'll now hand over to Warren.
WARREN VELLA: Thank you, Deb.
Hello, my name is
Warren Vella, and I
am the enterprise
integration architect
at the Australian
Energy Market Operator.
Today I'd like to talk
through how AEMO has partnered
with Google and
the Apigee platform
to unlock the power of our
existing data through APIs.
We'll take a look
at who AEMO is,
some of the unique challenges
the energy industry is facing,
and how APIs have
been instrumental
in our digital transformation.
So where does AEMO sit within
the Australian energy market?
AEMO is responsible for
the day-to-day operations
of the Australian
energy market, which
is made up of multiple
markets covering both gas
and electricity.
On one side, AEMO manages
the physical named
grid, the transmission
network, the large electricity
towers that you may have
seen around the country.
On the other side, AEMO operates
the financial energy markets
to enable energy flow all
the way from generation
to the customer
households via retailers.
As you can see, some of the
actors in the energy markets
are typical,
large-scale generators,
such as coal power
plants and wind
farms, all the way to
metadata providers, who
are responsible for sending
the metadata from households
to AEMO.
Sometimes this is
automated via smart meters,
and sometimes this
is manually read.
One of the biggest shifts we
are seeing in the energy market
is the active role of
the customer, who is now
also playing a critical
part of the grid,
especially as power is starting
to flow two-way, as into houses
and now out of houses.
Let's take a look at some
of the technology challenges
that the energy industry faces.
If we look deeper into the
national electricity market,
which was built
over 20 years ago,
the systems are largely are
connected over either SCADA
operational systems over private
networks or market data--
for example, dispatch data,
which is an instruction sent
to a generator
every five minutes--
or bids and offers
into the market,
which is received from
generators and retailers,
is still sent over to AEMO
by batch-based systems
over private networks.
With the increase of DER
penetration across Australia,
which is leading the world,
we have a unique opportunity
to unlock the value in our
data over modern protocols.
And so what can
AEMO do about this?
We have a unique
opportunity where
we are seeing an intersection
between the energy industry
transformation and our
digital transformation.
And as part of our
digital transformation,
we are tapping into
these opportunities
to enable new channels to really
lower the barrier to entry,
promoting further
competition in the market.
And as we digitize
our systems, we
are looking to foster innovation
within the energy market,
especially in the space
of distributed energy.
More importantly, we
are seeing the rise
of prosumers, who are looking
to take control of their energy
profile and play an active part
in this energy transformation.
And so working with
Apigee has enabled
us to start this journey as we
look to reach a wider audience.
Our new Apigee development
portal arms us with the tools
to create a world-class
developer experience,
accelerate API adoption,
simplify learning,
and increase the business
value of our APIs.
Developers are the key
consumers of our APIs,
and we want to provide them
with a great experience
and make it really easy
for them to discover,
understand, test, and
get going with our APIs,
from having an interactive
sandbox to test
our APIs to letting developers
manage their own keys
and access to the APIs,
and not necessarily
in an open-for-all approach
but with the right guardrails
that Apigee offers.
Our Apigee developer
portal has all the tools
a developer needs to
integrate with us.
Let's take a look at some
of our large-scale programs
and opportunities to unlock
the value of our data.
The energy industry
is moving along
with many programs, centered
around a common theme
in distributed energy resources.
Starting with the distributed
energy resource register,
DER register allows
registration of DER assets
sitting behind the meter--
for example, rooftop solar
panels and household batteries.
APIs have enabled for
this data to be registered
via the existing tools
and mobile applications
that electricians and
installers already used to.
The virtual power
plant trial has
started to advance
the integration of DER
into the national
electricity market,
allowing consumers
to group together
to become a virtual power plant.
APIs have enabled for the
management of these VPPs,
especially in the transfer
of telemetry data.
And in the space of
five-minute settlements,
the market is moving to more
granular data and settlement
down to five minutes.
APIs have enabled for meter
data at five-minute resolution
to be sent across the country
to aim as metadata management
database.
Next we'll take a
look at the CDR.
The CDR is a national
legislative program,
which is running across
multiple industries,
with the energy
industry next in line.
The CDR aims to give consumers
better access to their own data
and also allows competition by
using a data-driven, innovation
approach.
So let's take a look at
how we are using the Apigee
platform to support
the CDR as a use case.
Some of the key areas of
why Apigee has been selected
was the choice of
implementation options,
especially with the
hybrid option giving us
even more flexibility on
where to host our APIs,
whether that is in the
Google Cloud platform
or in our private cloud.
Data sovereignty is
especially important
as we operate national
critical infrastructure,
and the flexibility
of the platform
allows us to host
the platform to many
of our strict obligations for
the protection of our data.
And so the main focus
of the Apigee platform
is to manage our
externally facing APIs.
In the case of the
CDP, this allows
us to expose data from our
metadata management systems.
And like most
organizations, we have
data spread over multiple cloud
platforms and on-prem systems,
and Apigee allows us
to unify the experience
when integrating with our APIs.
Apigee is truly enabling
our digital transformation
as we renovate our internal
systems from legacy integration
protocols to modern
API ecosystems.
Now we'll take a
look at a live demo
and explore how the
Victorian government is
using our APIs to provide
a comparison service
for Australian consumers.
Here we have an example
of an external consumer.
The Victorian government
energy comparison website,
who was consuming
the AEMO's CDP APIs
to provide real-time metadata
retrieval from AEMO's metadata
management systems.
And before the CDP
APIs were available,
the end user needed to
complete over 10 questions,
and in some cases, a PDF
bill had to be uploaded.
Now that the API's
available, the user only
needs to know their
national metering
identifier, or their
NMI, and the data
is retrieved live from our API.
I'll now hand it off to Deb to
walk us through a live demo.
DEBORA ELKIN: The demo
we're about to see
is from the point of view of the
consumer wanting to understand
which energy retailer
offers the best
rates for the particular
electricity consumption
patterns.
I start looking around,
and I find a public website
that has been set up by
the government of Victoria,
Australia.
When this website
was first launched,
the website would estimate
the energy consumption pattern
based on a series of answers
provided by the consumer.
This was the simplest
option but still
required a lot of
information to be provided.
The other option
was for the consumer
to upload a PDF
copy of their bill.
I will now start answering all
the questions I am being asked.
After providing
this information,
I also need to provide the
details of my last electricity
bill.
At this point, I can
finally see which
rates are the most convenient
to my particular situation.
But I had to answer more than
ten questions to get here.
And still, it is
just an estimate.
Let us now see how
APIs that expose data
can improve my user
experience, as well as provide
more accurate results.
So let's start again.
This time I will choose
a different method
for building my energy
profile, quick and accurate.
This looks promising.
All I need to provide is a NMI.
This is a unique identifier
for the smart meter installed
in my house.
I can find it in my
electricity bill.
This option is now
powered by AEMO.
What this means is that
when I click on Get My Data,
this website uses an AEMO API
to retrieve the actual energy
consumption for my house
in the last 12 months.
This provides a very
accurate picture
on how I consume energy.
Voila, I can now see the rates
best suited to my household
without having to go through
a lengthy questionnaire.
I, as a consumer,
didn't even need
to see the raw data
coming back from the API.
This useful experience
is facilitated
by the API published by AEMO.
Looking at AEMO's API
portal, a developer
can easily find
the relevant APIs
and understand how to use them.
In this demo, we can
appreciate the advantages
of unlocking data via APIs.
This is a public
government website
that leverages information
held by AEMO to provide
a much better user experience.
Not only are the suggestions
more accurate to the consumer,
but also the consumer can see
them in a couple of clicks.
Thank you for watching it.
WARREN VELLA: So what's
next for AEMO and Apigee?
One of our main focus areas is
to enable DER resources to be
integrated into the grid,
which will increase API
calls to millions per day
as we start to receive
more and more telemetry data.
And for the CDP API, we are
looking to expand this service
and enable data service
holders to also provide
data via the CVR gateway model.
We are always looking to reduce
our participant onboarding time
and pivoting off
our developer portal
to provide the right
amount of information
and further reduce the time
to first, "Hello world."
And of course, our
API product portfolio
is expanding as we continue to
transform our systems as APIs
become our primary
form of integration
for our critical market systems.
Thank you for your
time, and I'll now
hand it back to Deb for
some closing remarks.
DEBORA ELKIN: Thank you, Warren.
Today we looked at how APIs
can be used to securely expose
your data and how the
Australian Energy Market
Operator is doing this.
We want to thank you for
watching this session,
and if you'd like to
continue the conversation,
we have set up some
expert one-on-one sessions
over the next couple of weeks.
And of course, we will
also be answering questions
you submit in the
question and answer
section for this session.
Thank you.